yeah i got already got the request
started here we go on new game um
let's play d4
what we got here sloth
yeah usually i'm i really play the
exchange variation
okay let's uh let's go for the exchange
it's not the most inspiring choice but
um
can i say i have a pretty good score the
silly 94 line i always forget to
to look at this properly
it's not so bad yeah
well silly is um just
it's not it's not a bad line it's it's
just that i tend to forget to
to look at this and every time it's got
someone plays it i ask myself well what
what do i do
do against this and well okay
i lost the game pretty quickly um
against this not um not so long ago
but this was a very strong opponent um
not sure um it was very high rated and i
lost
terribly and also very quickly
i think it was it was quite similar to
this
okay
yeah not sure if black's um
play with knight x e5 was so great that
f6 is just looking ugly
but okay it's
shouldn't be too serious
okay you always have this
irritating queen a5
maybe i should just check myself
and queen d7 um either play queen b3
but then you can most likely just
exchange off everything on c4 and play
rook c8
it's not not a big deal
if i take he i think i must take him
with the king
maybe then c5 bishop b5 maybe this is an
idea
check
so on b6 which would be normal
position only um i have bishop b5
and then it's uncomfortable for him
yeah maybe this is not so bad rook b1 is
also an idea because this
bishop on g3 always controls the b8
square
this is also an issue with the bishop
placement here on
on g7 the this bishop is just doing
nothing
this one on e6 is also not so great
yeah maybe this is quite nice i'm also
i'm only a little bit
bad in development so
unless he's got some
concrete way to to open it up quickly
this should be fine
hmm okay
no idea what this move is doing
or maybe he wants to reposition the
bishop d7 c6 or maybe it's not so bad
maybe c6 is an interesting move
c6 if he takes bishop a6
then rook b1
hmm
this could be an idea it's not
not stupid at all or maybe bishop b5
on bishop d7 then rook b1
yeah okay come on i need to speed up i'm
down to two minutes already
now this one
okay what now
yeah okay
the idea would be now to take and then
try to
get quickly on the on the blb file
still have this bishop here
but he'll he will have e5 of course
yeah he's just quick enough with rook bh
hmm yeah well that's a shame
maybe f4
and f5 the idea well
maybe this is an idea a tactical one
yeah of course
the idea would be if he takes on f4 i
take with the bishop and i i'm all in
wait on b7 or b8
if he takes on d4 i've got f5 check this
is the idea
okay time warning
well this would would give me an extra
pawn
isn't this just just winning which i
should be just winning
check i get the king to d4 and play e4
it's just an extra pawn in the king and
pawn end game
check
okay let's only try to be precise here
yeah it didn't really matter this pawn
moves
the pawn is just going through
well i'm not the fastest player
okay
interesting yeah not sure maybe
this was a form
maybe it was a good idea i'm not sure
what uh what what he should do
it looks uncomfortable i think
yeah maybe he should just take on b3 and
then play rookie 8 of
course
yeah maybe this is just yeah this
should be okay
yeah okay well then taking was fine
but now he has to play rookie adrian
maybe that's the only move even but
of course only move is sufficient if
it's if it's okay
yeah should be fine let's check quickly
with the comp rookie 8 yeah
yeah 0.4 for white
yeah what this position um
can only be something for white if if we
will get something
really quickly because strategically my
bishop is not very very good on
on g3 i've got all the pawns on on dark
squares so
i need to open it up quickly in order to
invade with the rook
so almost all end games with rook
exchanges
should be should be okay for black at
least maybe even um
even advantage for black but um
i've got this um this active rook on b3
so
yeah rookie 8 is maybe just equal but he
didn't he didn't find it
or he assessed something wrong there
i'm not sure yeah well this is okay if
he takes on
b three hours f e6 or takes on f6
so it takes on f6 here so
this was just winning yeah okay
next game